just on the way out we were shown
something really special this is what
ramen used to carry in his overcoat
pocket it's his personal spectroscope so
whenever he saw something interesting a
flower a rock whatever he could look
through this and see the spectrum of its
color this is really special because
ramen is most famous for his work on
spectroscopy and here is his personal
spectroscope the thing that he really
carried around and valued it's like
Isaac Newton's telescope or something
like that this is as close as one can
get to a scientist who's sadly died here
you can see the tools that he used not
when he was doing big experiments but
when he was relaxing you can imagine him
look nice flower and that go looks at it
so we're very privileged this is
something I hope all of you who are
watching will remember
so this is the citation and here is you
can perhaps guess is the medal Wow
if I put this near the lamp well I
wonder I've never tried it there he goes
it's whizzing around that's fantastic
that's really good I've never tried that
at first you did send a bit alarm guys I
don't know what